this is Jocko podcast number 144 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening and a few
episodes back I referenced an interview
that I had read with colonel david
hackworth the author of about face my my
favorite book of all time check and it
was actually on on podcast number 142
and I referenced this interview and I
said I would cover it in the future on a
podcast so here we are 144 the interview
is from pbs.org if they had a show
called
people's century and inside that show
inside that series there was one part of
it I guess maybe it was an episode it
was called the guerrilla war so we're
gonna take a look at that also on top of
that to expand on some of the topics I'm
also gonna take a look at a book called
Vietnam primer and it's it's a pretty
cool book it's very tactical and when I
say tactical I'm not talking about I'm
talking actual tactical like it shows
where you should put your security
elements while you're in Vietnam what's
the best way to maneuver through the
jungle in Vietnam it's very very
specific to that kind of jungle fighting
but there are definitely some topics in
it that I wanted to pull out and that is
the book in about face when Hackworth is
talking about working with SLA Marshall
which we covered his book on 142 he's
talking about how he worked with him and
they wrote when they got done with going
and interviewing all these people they
wrote the book Vietnam primer and so I
wanted to at least take a look at that I
probably won't cover it in any great
depth on the podcast because it's so
tactical and it's very specific to that
time and maybe I'll cover it someday but
because you never know well anyways
there's definitely some things to get
out of it
that III want to look at and we'll pull
some of those up today but the basis is
to look at this this interview with
hackworth and I think you're gonna see
it takes a lot of stuff from about-face
and just really puts it in the clear in
the clear so here we go people century
guerrillas guerrilla Wars and this is
the interview with david hackworth from
PBS what do you think the Vietcong learn
learned from melts a tongue and
Hackworth says I think the major thing
was how a poor man fights a rich man how
a war can be fought employing ancient
rules first developed by Sun Tzu the
need for patience the need for political
motivation the need to fight a war of
economy and how to employ all the rules
of warfare so there you go that's a
little way to start this thing off the
need for patience the need for political
motivation he gets he gets into this and
he talks a lot about talks a lot about
the economy because that's something
that you can lose track of as a
frontline person but you need to think
about it next this is this very
interesting what lessons should the
Americans have learned from the French
defeat so the French got beat in Vietnam
and here's what hack Werth says well I
think the major lesson they should have
learned was that that war didn't involve
the security of France and the security
of the United States wasn't at issue
either on a tactical level they didn't
have an objective they didn't have an
objective on the tactical alert
so clearly the point is you have to have
an objective hmm he goes on the
Americans should have studied the
lessons of the French very closely and
taken something from them a
correspondent once asked to general
Westmoreland the American commanding
general and architect of the war what he
thought of how the French fought the war
and was he studying the lessons of the
French he said why should I study the
lessons of the French
they haven't won a war since Napoleon
this was the attitude of American total
arrogance we didn't learn from the past
we didn't learn from our own experience
by going back to when we beat Britain in
1776 at that time the British had argued
that we didn't fight in formations such
as there's a big block formation we
didn't meet them in the open and fought
like and we fought like the Indians
behind trees using concealment and cover
and so on and a couple hundred years
later we had the British mentality
towards fighting and we had forgotten
the lessons that we had taught the
British that Sting's doesn't it you know
when that ego gets out of control you
know can you think about that think
about that that quote from Westmoreland
is awful why should I study the lessons
of French they hadn't won a war since
Napoleon yeah that's that's that's awful
to read that is why that is why the the
seals that when I was running training
the seals that would get fired the
leader the seals that would get fired
for leadership problems or from
leadership positions they were beginning
fired because of that attitude right
there they don't listen to anybody and
and what's interesting about this
hackworth is actually saying the loos
you should actually even listen to the
loser hmm put that ego in check
next question don't you think that the
United States tremendous firepower could
have won the war Hackworth the war could
never have been won in terms of the
employment of firepower the solution to
winning the war was to cause reform in
the government to win the hearts and
minds of the people to make the cause
justifiable so that the people of the
country were willing to give up their
lives this was not done you could have
used all the firepower in the world
all the technical ability that the US
had to fight the enemy and you'd have
maybe won a temporary tactical respite
that's that's important cuz you know
something sometimes you think yourself
well if we just if we put enough bombs
on them yeah well we can shut them down
I mean short of nuking them but I think
that's important he's saying you could
maybe possibly win because I I think
myself yeah I mean if you drop enough
bombs on people you know you can you get
in and shut them down but he's saying
you can you can win a tactical a
temporary tactical respite back to the
interview but we'd never won a war
strategically unless we had people had
the people join our side we didn't read
that again but we'd never have won the
war
strategically unless we had the people
on our side the war was about the people
and winning over their hearts and their
minds and their allegiance to the host
country the host country in Vietnam was
made up of gangsters next question but
you weren't there as a soldier to win
hearts and minds you were there strictly
for military purposes Hackworth if you
were a student of warfare if you were a
student of warfare as I was you quickly
realized that tactically we were not
going to win the war and we had to win
the people and this is basically the
same conclusion you know when I when I
got to Iraq the second time and I saw
the Intel reports and and saw that what
we were doing was the capture kill
missions and and I saw that they had as
many targets you know I was in Iraq 2003
2004 and they had as many targets up on
the wall in 2006 when I got back as they
had when I left
mm-hmm so that to me said this is just
that when is this we is this ever gonna
stop it didn't look like it to me we had
to do something different and that's
when I read the counterinsurgency manual
my second day on deployment or something
like that and and figured out what he
was saying right there he had that you
had to take care of the people next
question so were the efforts to resettle
whole villages of Viet
mieze a good way to fight this war
Hackworth no because the Americans again
tried to impose their values on the
country of Vietnam without understanding
the culture and the religion of Vietnam
it was a country made up of Buddhists
who worshiped ancestors frequently
listen to us frequently people who'd
been moved from their homes would go
through minefields to get back to
worship at the graves of their ancestors
we didn't understand that we didn't
understand what the Vietnamese culture
was all about so imagine that you think
you can just you think you just move
people around yeah that's no no actually
you can't do that that that ground is
holy to them that grand is where their
family is they have deep rooted ties and
we didn't recognize that next question
what do you think was so particularly
good about the Viet congs guerrilla
fighters what did you as a military man
respect about them most
hackworth I respected their dedication
the fire in their belly their great
strong belief in freedom so that's
interesting because of course we're
looking at them we're looking at the
Vietnamese thinking they're communist
and they're we think we're fighting for
for freedom right but and this is other
this is a fairly common opinion about
Vietnam is that they just didn't want
outsiders but they saw any outsiders
were were imposing on their freedom so
even if we were gonna bring glorious
democracy it wasn't their glorious
democracy they want it yeah back to the
interview there's was a mission a
complete dedication to winning
independence for their country so there
you have it
so I respected them for for where they
were coming from maybe it was empathy my
ancestors two or three hundred years ago
had fought for the British or sorry had
fought the British what about their
strategy and tactics Hackworth as
fighters they were very fanatical and
very dedicated they were like my
paratroopers who
were extraordinarily fine soldiers a
soldier tends to respect a counterpart
that's a heavyweight and they were
indeed heavyweights because of their
devotion to the cause next question a
female gorilla leader said that
sometimes when they shot an American
soldier his comrades would come up to
get the body and then they'd all burst
into tears which she said was a
wonderful opportunity to shoot them or
to grab their weapons is that a fair
comment Hackworth it's right on the mark
the problem with Americans fighting that
war was that as the war went on they
lost leadership they lost their hardcore
professional leaders a professional
soldier does not go after wounded he
leaves that to the medics but soldiers
that are not well trained and not well
disciplined by their leaders tend to
become more of a group of fraternity
buddies who care very much for their
fallen comrade and who want to get him
out of the line of fire in Vietnam it
was known that the standard technique to
use was to hit the first guy then take
out anybody going after him that was how
they'd add to their casualty list I have
had my soldiers tell me that a guy might
have been hit in the leg in a Hopf
firefight and his opponent only 10 or 15
feet away would be pointing at pointing
his weapon at him giving him the finger
doing all these things to tease him
while he's waiting for someone to come
out and pull him away then they could
blow that guy away to prioritize and
execute you've got to know what the most
important problem you've got and it's
not the wounded guy it's the guy that's
trying to kill you and you got to be
able to you gotta train your guys to be
able to overcome that emotional
situation that they're going through
because that's gonna be the instinct
that's the human instinct next question
the Vietcong hit in the jungle but in
the Mekong Delta there really isn't any
jungle so where did the Vietcong hide I
like this answer
hackworth well they were hidden in the
jungle that was always alongside the
waterways which tended to be very thick
and well booby-trapped out in front they
were hidden by the people they hid in
the waterways they would get underwater
and take a reed and put it above the
water and breathe through that then
surround themselves with a bit of
floating NEFA grass they would dig caves
under the waterways and then put a bit
of reed up to the top and breathe
through that they were very very cunning
fighters yeah that's that's like what
you hear about in the movies right a
little weed yeah breathing through a
reed and they're actually doing that he
goes into that more here next question
did you have any personal experience of
finding Vietcong lurking under the water
surface hackworth Oh commonly if we saw
a bit of nipa floating down a waterway a
bit of jungle debris we fired at it in
invariably it would turn red that meant
there was that below was a Vietcong
hanging on to the roots of the debris
with a reed going up to get air and we'd
killed one enemy once we located them I
always took concertina wire and put it
on both sides of the creek so they
couldn't float down they'd run into the
wire I instructed my soldiers to fire at
any foliage and in most cases there
would be a Vietcong hanging on trying to
get out they were simply the most
skilful the most dedicated the best
opponent I've struck in almost 50 years
of being around soldiers there the best
question what other problems were unique
in the Mekong Delta the problem in the
Delta was not only the terrible
conditions that prevailed there but it
was the impact it had on your soldiers
I'm speaking now as an American we had
terrible casualties from what we called
immersion foot immersion foot was the
problem in World War one called trench
foot after being in the water for a long
time the feet would become very soft and
the boot rubbing against the foot would
become very abrasive suddenly you've had
it you'd have a hole in your foot the
size of a bullet hole and suddenly
you're a lost soldier
we had to be you had to be very wary and
take care of the feet there was no place
to sleep so you were in the water at
night your soldiers were in the water
and you stayed miserable and wet my rule
was that a unit could only stay in the
field for five days after five days
immersion foot set in so badly that a
whole battalion of 800 men could be laid
up for weeks
I got a merchant foot one time then I
got legit immersion foot and wear so I
was doing a training exercise in it was
added it was we were doing a training
exercise doing a reconnaissance of an
airfield that was located around the
swamp so I spent five or six days in
this swamp and not the whole five or six
days but a good amount of days and plus
the days I wasn't in the swamp there was
a heavy rain so just my feet were wet
for an extended period of time actually
on this particular training exercise
when we were going into the field it was
raining when we got in the field that
started sleeping you know like like ice
and that turned to snow and so it was
right around you know and then in the
daytime it warmed up and it would turn
back to rain but it was a pretty
miserable six days but when I got out of
the field and and quite frankly I didn't
really understand the threat of
immersion foot and so I just kept my
boots on probably almost the whole time
and when I got out my feet were really
jacked up really jacked up as a matter
of fact I was looking at some pictures
just to see how bad I had it compared to
how bad it can get I just looked at some
pictures on you know on the interwebs
and my feet were jacked up legit what I
mean obviously this is I mean I've never
heard immersion foot but that's a
comrade a trench foot right yeah yeah so
that's common knowledge right yeah
because remember uh Forrest Gump when he
said that when he's like Lieutenant Dan
I'm coming to tell you things or
whatever and one of them was keep your
sock keep your dryer yeah yeah yes well
that's definitely a common thing then he
he talks about it a lot you know gotta
get inspect guys feet make sure that
you're good to go yeah what guys feet
aren't good to go
they're done can't walk you're done but
my feet from that immersion foot they
were numb they would know I'm like dead
why cuz it got colder word it was the
worse is just the wetness yeah well he
was cold
it only snowed and rent it only was
below freezing that first night and then
it was warmer but they were wet for a
long time yeah that was when I was young
and then when you take a lead um take
off your shoes does it like to the pain
set in then or no they were actually
they went that they went they didn't
hurt at no they did but they didn't hurt
they could hurt more when I got out of
the field yeah that's and they started
to hurt yeah they were actually numb
yeah cuz I mean the wood the way I
imagined it is like you know I don't
know you're in the pool or the bath you
know when you're a kid you in the bath
we're like super super long it all get
the wrinkle yeah yeah the prunes pruned
up feet bad times five days yeah going
like too far yeah because they seem kind
of sensitive to when you think about it
you know like it's like oh man so next
next question why were you men in the
water why didn't they walk along the
banks or along pathways between paddy
fields Hackworth you could expect any
dry surface was mined and booby-trapped
and 60% of all casualties we had in
Vietnam came from mines and booby traps
laid I might add by those local
guerrillas who the generals at the top
Westmoreland and assistance didn't count
so he's saying the local guerrillas they
talk about how the the generals like
Westmoreland would say oh you know
there's this many people and they
wouldn't count the local populace or
these local guerrillas as insurgents uh
continuing they didn't believe that they
were the enemy because their mentality
was a world war two mentality they
didn't understand the nature of the war
they were refighting world war two and
they thought they could win the war by
applying heavy firepower the outpourings
of Detroit and great technological
ability
they thought they would steamroll this
opponent into defeat they found that a
war could not be won with bulldozers
against somebody fighting with the great
cause next question but after the Tet
Offensive didn't the heavy bombing raids
actually take a very heavy toll on the
Vietcong Hackworth well general LeMay
said if I had enough bombs I could win
this war because I'd blast the
Vietnamese back to the Stone Age what he
didn't understand was that the
Vietnamese were already living in the
Stone Age and that firepower wouldn't
work under those circumstances I do
think you're correct that at the end of
Tet 1968 February 1968 we increase the
amount of bomb tonnage out of
frustration Vietnam is a country about
the size of California in terms of area
we used three times the amount of bombs
in the Vietnam War as we did in all of
World War two both the Allies and the
axis
how's that for just completely insane we
put enough steel on that California size
target to sink it and it did not cause
the opponent to give in firepower was
not the answer the answer was to win the
hearts and minds of the people question
why didn't fire power work Hackworth
well what fire power did using pursuit
aircraft fighter aircraft fighter
bombers artillery mortar and so on what
it did was it galvanized the opponent it
puts steel in their back they could see
themselves being struck by a giant and
they had no way no recourse to strike
back it as it did historically with the
British in World War two it put fire in
their belly it was absolutely the worst
thing we could do in Vietnam it gave
them a tonic to fight harder so we've
covered that on the podcast about how
the Brits when the Brits got bombed
psychologically it made them tougher hmm
because there's something happening like
this this massive attack comes well it
seems like a massive attack it's
something you can't control something
you can't
back but when you bomb a city of a
million people there's actually a small
number of that kid that actually get
impacted by it and so everyone else goes
hey we can survive this yeah and so
that's what happened with the Vietnamese
they oh you drop these giant bombs on us
guess what I'm still here you can't do
anything to me
America big America with your big bombs
I'm still I'm still right here yeah what
do you got mmm now I'll tell you what if
the reason fighting in in Iraq against
Isis there's been a lot of bombing in
the bombing has been let's just say it
was very very productive very very
productive and and they killed a lot a
lot thousands and tens of thousands of
Isis fighters and even with that being
said there was ground forces that had to
move in but man they did a lot of
devastating devastating destruction the
enemy with that stuff so I think in
certain situations you can have a
massive impact with firepower yeah but
isn't that like like I you say like the
isn't that like because of intelligence
that they had and stuff like there was
more more to it than just hey let's just
yeah yeah here are a bunch and and the
ISIS or easier targets and not only not
only easier targets but better weapon
tree because man if you look at the
number like I remember reading something
about a bridge that they were trying to
take out in Vietnam and they launched
mission after mission after mission
after mission him drop bomb after bomb
after it's hard it was hard back then to
to actually hit something like a bridge
over the wrong gotcha okay you know what
I'm saying we'll have to get we'll have
to get Dave Burke on here good deal team
yeah good deal Dave we'll have to get
him on here and and talk about how hard
that is to with dumb bombs keynote
everyone says smart bombs not those were
dumb bombs you had to basically you
gotta eyeball it yeah yeah I thought
miss Lee I imagine how hard that is like
okay we get that if you just want to
bomb this general the city yeah right
you can just drop bombs on the city okay
I get you can hit that but you're trying
to hit a bridge yeah can you imagine how
hard that's got to be yeah I do
because I used to play this game called
Mario Kart right so it's like a split
screen and let's track and get these
weapons right and you're playing your
friend who's sitting right next to you
because it's split screen and you can
pick up these weapons so to the weapons
were the turtle shell it's a red one and
a green one the red one was a smart
turtle shell it like seek the other guy
out but the green one just went in the
exact direction that you shot it so
imagine you're on a track you're taking
turns just way harder with a green shell
you know back in Vietnam was a green
shell here nowadays we got the red shell
you pretty much fully understand this
check alright with that we'll go back to
the interview next question when you
were active in the Mekong Delta was it
difficult to tell who was Vietcong and
who was civilian hackworth I was in the
9th division and our commander was
general Julian Yule who was called the
butcher of the Delta the policy of the
division was that it didn't matter if it
moved shoot it and then count it
theoretically civilians were supposed to
be away from the battle area they would
say this as if they would say this is a
free fire zone but without realizing the
tradition of the people to go back to
their homestead so regardless of the
danger they would go back to where their
ancestors were and then they were
considered Vietcong and fair game there
were an enormous number of casualties
who were civilians but all the civilians
you have to understand were sympathetic
certainly in my part of the Delta to the
Vietcong effort most of the people in
the rural areas of Vietnam were
sympathetic to the Vietcong cause they
had won the hearts and minds of the
Vietnamese people they felt that their
cause was more just it had a more
nationalistic purpose question you'll
once flying in a helicopter over the
Delta and you saw some people running
along and you fought there civilians
their children Hackworth yes one day we
were doing what's called eagle flies
which is a platoon of infantry
helicopters five six soldiers per
helicopter and I was controlling
everything in a command and control
helicopter the pilot in the front seat
of my helicopter said there are four
enemies streaking across
field request permission to fire as
commander I would grant that permission
I looked down and I saw four little kids
so I said negative those are little kids
they're just playing hooky from school
or something leave them alone and I went
ahead and inserted my platoon and let
them maneuver through the area
suddenly they took fire from those poor
little kids who were probably no more
than twelve or thirteen years old and
had stashed their ak-47s so I was wrong
my previous experience had been up in
the highlands that was one of my first
days in the Delta and I was learning
that just about anybody in that
battlefield sadly enough was a hostile
question were they ever helpful to you
hackworth again he hits it here 60% of
all casualties 60 percent of all US
casualties during that war or from mines
and booby traps that were set out by
these local people who had built them
and installed them ironically enough the
top generals never counted those people
as part of the enemy's order of battle
even though they accounted for about
300,000 people they were conveniently
dropped from the rolls
they were only counted when they were
found dead going into any battle area if
we picked up a civilian he became our
point man against the Geneva Convention
the assumption was that if this cat
lived here he knew how to get through
this area without losing a leg or a life
he could lead our forces through so
that's again we've covered this a bunch
but the local populace there's they're
walking through these down these trails
every single day and they're not hitting
any booby traps and then you lose a guy
today you lose a guy tomorrow eventually
you realize that they had a minimum they
know where these booby traps are and
Hackworth saying there that they're the
ones that set him up made him and set
him up oh yeah so it mentioned against
the Geneva Convention yet to grab a
civilian did so there they're sort of
grabbing them in what forcing them do it
like hey you're gonna walk yeah like
you're gonna walk out in front you're
gonna take us through this this trail
like a hostage yeah almost like a
hostage of source yeah
next question what was a simple booby
trap well the punji stakes was a
no-brainer normally they were set in a
position where they would strike your
ankle it would scratch you you in filthy
water you'd get an infection
I had a punji wound and I didn't know it
I must have got it in the morning and it
bled a lot I didn't know until I got out
of the water and looked at my boot and
it was soaking red from blood there was
a wound that looked very much like as if
someone had taken a razor and made about
a 3-inch long slash in my leg it became
infected that was the problem it wasn't
a long-term wound it was something that
put you down for a few days that had to
be cleaned out debrided then it would be
stitched up and you were find the real
killer was the coffee can filled with
explosives from a dud American round
everything they used we gave them we
threw away our c-ration cans we threw
away our used batteries we threw away
our coffee cans if a 500-pound bomb
didn't explode that provided them with
the raw materials for their booby traps
so they set up their booby trap Factory
they opened up the mine they took out
the explosives packed it in a can
wrapped barbed wire and nails and other
things around it got a primer device
from a grenade that was left behind put
a tripwire on it and set it on the side
of the road when the first soldier hit
it he would lose his life and maybe
three or four people behind him would be
down I've seen what we call number 10
cans the large cans packed full of c4
and so filled with nails to have a
fragment effect that it could take down
10 or 12 people the impact on the
soldier was a psychological impact that
every time you put your foot down you
didn't know whether you're going to have
a leg a limb or a life then this played
over and over for 365 days of going down
trails going down waterways it took the
fight out of you I took over the
battalion down at the Delta it was
called the hard luck battalion in six
months before I took it over
it had 600 casualties killed and wounded
all four mines and booby traps it had
never met the enemy it was all from
these insidious little devices put down
by these people that the generals didn't
count because they didn't understand the
nature of the war yeah and I think I
think the numbers for Iraq was 75% of
the casualties or from IEDs
you know 75% off to confirm that but it
whatever it was it's a huge number it's
a huge number it's it must be an odd
feeling to find that you know like dang
they made that bomb out of our stuff
like especially at first when you used
to it it's different like you're like
what if he came across the results of a
bomb and it's like dang I was just using
that coffee can you know like two days
ago or something like that well yeah
that's why discipline soldiers wouldn't
leave anything behind ever yeah
but lack of discipline soldiers would
leave all the stuff here now sometimes
you drop bombs and they don't detonate
that's so they can't really fire anyone
for that but yeah coffee cans and they
they they they taught us when I when I
when I was going through training mm-hmm
they taught us like we weren't allowed
to leave anything behind
yeah couldn't leave anything behind
because we didn't want the enemy to use
it yeah that's the way it was and you
know what the you know what the Iraqis
the Iraqis did the same thing the
insurgents I should say the insurgents
in Iraq they used old ordnance now some
of the old ordnance that they used was
actually from the old Iraqi army a lot
of it but a lot of it was from
unexploded ordnance just like what the
Vietcong used yeah and even to me it
kind of seems like even if it wasn't
stuff to use like I mean man it's a
spectrum like some you know how like
when Willian on the movie where the
Kurds the criminal they're chasing the
criminal with the dogs and then the
criminal left part of his shirt or
something and then the dog sort of
smells it it's like that feeling like
your enemy has like something in yours
right so he on one side of the spectrum
is like okay they use it to make bombs
right which is kind of just maybe
psychologically just kind of odd and
then just the fact that for example like
what if in Iraq you capture somebody or
whatever any of
like a pair of like some old army boots
or some bro yeah for sure buddy there's
well I'd say yeah that's that's a I see
it hitting you and I'm trying to figure
out why this is kind of shocking to you
yeah and it must be the first time
you've ever thought about this yeah yeah
easier for me like for instance this was
horrible so just think about this there
was an element of snipers that got
overrun in Ramadi mm-hmm and so think
about what the enemy got sniper weapons
night-vision gods always like you're
horrified night vision goggles and
sniper weapons so that it takes what you
were just talking about it multiplies at
times a lot yeah because now the enemy
has legitimate equipment that puts them
a little bit higher longer on the
tactical level so that's definitely
scary and that's why we're so careful
about never leaving anything behind yeah
next question what did these sorts of
casualties due to the morale of ammo of
American soldiers hackworth just blew it
away just like a mind blew away a leg
they just played with your mind months
after I left Vietnam I found myself
walking across an open field and I
suddenly said where am i and froze in my
mind I was in a minefield it took a few
minutes for me to work out that I was
not in a mine field I believe that a lot
of the so called Vietnam stress syndrome
that has created so many walking wounded
across America today is due to the
damage caused long ago by what they saw
of their mates going down by mines and
booby traps remember of the 60,000 dead
and 300,000 Americans wounded at war
60% were from mines and booby traps he
driving that point home the great irony
was that the infantry soldier infantry
soldiers who went to Vietnam received a
total of five hours of training in mines
and booby traps that was the curriculum
used in World War two we simply didn't
learn
I can tell you they turned up I mean
when I was running training but we went
crazy with IEDs like our our fake IEDs
but yeah we would get nuts with them we
put them all over the place and just you
had to you had to figure out what yet
you had to be careful yeah but I'll tell
you man it is hard when someone's good
at making those IDs and camouflaging
them scary yeah we'd have to like brief
the training cadre over and over again
to make sure the training cadre didn't
set off IEDs we would be building next
what was the purpose of the Vietcong
tunnels in the sort of cootchie area
north of Saigon
hackworth the purpose of the tunnels is
to provide safe areas for supplies for
their headquarters and for their
soldiers a great casualty producer for
them was artillery air bombing and
machine-gun strikes from aircraft and
helicopters most of the tunnels were
located in areas that had great
limestone formations it was easy to dig
in but still quite strong and easy to
shore up they could go down to three for
actual floors with pumped in air and
brought in water it gave them a secure
area that was really behind the American
lines and the Americans never really
worked out that they were there for
example there was a place called the
Iron Triangle there was a great number
of such tunnels and a general named
Williamson took a brigade in there and
said the Iron Triangle is no more that
was in 1965 at the beginning of the
American involvement in the war when the
North seized the country and they went
when they won the war in 1975 their
headquarters was in the Iron Triangle in
those very caves that's that's like
another situation you call this area
secure and the enemy has actually has
their headquarters there crazy
next question wasn't it possible to
block up the tunnels or gas them or blow
them up Hackworth we tried everything
possible to destroy the tunnels
including having small soldiers called
tunnel rats go down and try and clear
them but they were so cleverly done you
could never find where the actual
was there would be a dead end with a
hidden door going down to the next level
I'm sure that if enough creativity and
effort had gone into it then yes they
could have been closed up but the top
generals were not concerned an anecdote
a cave expert came to me between my
tours in Vietnam in my office in the
Pentagon he said look I can help you in
the war I can tell you where the caves
are because this is something I've
studied my whole life I took him to my
boss a Vietnam veteran who is very
excited about it we took him to our
general and he didn't want to know about
it who wants to waste money sending this
guy over there and have him examined
tunnels and caves what's he gonna tell
us again it was the mentality that
firepower will win the war these great
outpourings of American industrial
strength will win this war this
arrogance didn't allow us to get beyond
a blinkered military mindset good advice
for life in this this is something that
with echelon frontal working with a lot
of businesses sometimes your strategy is
wrong and it was Lou isn't that this
what happened in Iraq with us our
strategy was not working it took us some
time to figure that out and start doing
a counterinsurgency campaign but I see
this was businesses a lot too they're
using some strategy and it's not working
but maybe they used it 12 years ago
maybe they used it two years ago and it
worked and and they were celebrated and
now there's gonna do it harder yeah do
the same strategy more seems like that's
the case with marketing you know
marketing just changes so much you know
like when you're marketed to the new
strategies that it's not as obvious but
the old strategies you know like
door-to-door salesmen oh yeah
door-to-door salesman comes to your
house now bro didn't want to hear it but
why did you even come to my house well
that's like wouldn't that be considered
just a complete waste cuz you got to pay
some kid for whatever 12 bucks an hour
to go door-to-door whereas you can pay
12 bucks and send out of I don't know an
email or something yeah but even he
knows well yeah that's what's the deal
even that's kind of old now but the no
door-to-door there was a time where
door-to-door was dope you know it's fun
I still talk to people that will go out
and make stuff happen door-to-door oh
yeah so now it's old school again right
when the multiples coming back
here's the thing usually door to door
seems like a hard sell
so sure they'll make things happen but
it's not as efficient as other ways like
newer ways of marking yeah these people
come to my house
door-to-door people they want to sell me
stuff yeah yeah how many times have you
bought zero yeah so that's the point
running through my mind to see if if
that was a solid answer I'm actually I'm
actually pretty sure that in the last 20
years I've bought zero from door-to-door
salesmen right Bo and one that's
probably common we're here I mean
consider the feeling you have when
someone comes but elders so there's some
people that make money ready to get
obviously yeah yeah yeah and I'm not
saying no there one is that somebody's
I've worked with some companies where
they did you door-to-door sales yeah but
I got some good sales kids they're
selling a good product you're like okay
we're gonna get this out there right so
an antique on doors yeah I dig it but
there was the time back in the day when
door-to-door was kind of adult thing
mm-hmm okay and when you think about it
it would make sense because door-to-door
like back long time we remember people
used to come over they just knock on the
door if there wasn't cellphone or
nothing like that if they were super
courteous they would call before they
came but if that's your neighbor your
friend or whatever people not gonna door
all the time now people don't just show
up at your door that's true go out there
cuz they're lazy also yeah I'm sorry
tackle you home yeah that's what I'm
saying so but back in the day during
door salesman they were put it this way
they weren't as unwelcome as they are
now right so as they work there was more
random people showing up for your house
yeah there's a bunch of reasons this is
what I'm saying but that the point is
back in the day that marketing technique
or that sales technique or whatever was
was more effective than it is now I'm
not saying it's a zero effective not
saying is way more you know cuz things
change so if you're a company you're
like hey I think door to door zone is
the way to go because back in you know
seventy five and we were killing you
know kind of thing
well that was what's interesting so
going back to Iraq and going away from
door to door sales here
yeah the that was interesting about the
surge what was the surge was not just
more people it was new strategy it was a
more counterinsurgency focused strategy
and luckily that we shifted that
strategy because it wasn't going well up
until that point next question
but these tunnels were militarily
significant weren't they
Hackworth they were a running sore from
the beginning to the end and they were a
very powerful ally of the Vietcong
question you in the States at the time
it happened but do you remember hearing
about the Tet Offensive in 1968
Hackworth when the TAT offense have
occurred in 1968 I was in the Pentagon a
dear friend of mine was an aide to a
very senior general so he was privy to a
lot of information that we Indians
didn't have meaning the lower ranking
guys as opposed to the Chiefs Indians he
came and whispered in my ear and he told
me about the attack long before hours
before anyone in the press or public
knew anything about it
I was quite frankly shocked and
heartbroken I had been convinced for two
years that the Vietcong were going to
win the war but the Americans simply
didn't understand the nature of the war
it was very much epitomized when Walter
Cronkite asked the American people what
the hell's going on here I thought we
were winning the war that was the kind
of shock it was to the American people
everyone had been fed these glowing
after-action reports by the President
Lyndon Johnson by general Westmoreland
that there was light at the end of the
tunnel that we were prevailing that it
would only be a matter of months the
American public was still oriented
towards World War two they were
believing that as long as we grabbed
this real estate we would eventually
find the light at the end of the tunnel
but the light at the end of the tunnel
was a Vietcong freight train coming on
full bore that's what we discovered in
Tet of 1968 and that was the turning
point of the war question why was a de
turning point
worth tat was a turning point because it
destroyed the will of the American
people to support the war those soldiers
who were in the know realized that this
was just the beginning of the end we saw
that the American people switched off if
the support of the people is not there
you are going to be cut off at the legs
and that's exactly what happened in
Vietnam and this is when I was on that
show on the History Channel the warriors
show and and I talked about how you had
to have the will to kill and the will to
die and to show about Mark Lee and
that's that's where that quote that I
that statement that I made is rooted in
what I learned from Acworth that is you
have to have this will you have to have
the will and the people the nation has
to have the will it's not just the
military has to have the will it's the
people because what is what is the
military the military is the people back
to the interview there had been a fair
amount of support for the war until Tet
of 1968 people thought it would be
unpatriotic not to hang in there and
wait until we grabbed annoy when we when
the people saw Viet Cong climbing on the
top of the American Embassy they knew
that they'd been lied to
then they knew that this war was not
winnable all they had to do is ask their
sons by that time I'm probably a million
Americans had served in Vietnam and had
come back home and told their parents
and loved ones the truth about the war
the government couldn't just provide it
with a Madison Avenue snow job any more
question could the war have been won
could the Vietcong have been beaten
Hackworth the war could not have been
won unless the host country the Saigon
government the South Vietnamese changed
their very repressive form of government
and won the hearts and minds of the
people there the northern government had
employed this technique and they've
created the promise of this utopian
dream as soon as they kicked out the
invader this repressive South Vietnamese
government the South Vietnamese
government never understood why what
never understood that they had to make
those changes
they were led by greedy people who were
into making money they had no contact
with the people in the main they were
mainly Catholics and they were in - they
were and they were trying to rule a
country that was 90% Buddhist question
why was body count so important or was
it hackworth McNamara was a number
cruncher and he wanted to have something
to crunch a number the overall strategy
was attrition to wear out the enemy by
counting bodies we would know the impact
of the war its success or failure that
became the standard measurement of
success it was the score and everyone
wanted to know the score what really
happened was the body count counting
completely eroded the honor code of the
military specifically among the officer
corps they taught people to lie
the young fresh lieutenants out of the
military academies were taught to lie
the generals who were pretty proficient
liars anyway pushed the body count a
high body count meant great success so
in every battle enemy bodies were
counted several times if there were 200
bodies suddenly the figure became 650
and it became to quote with Westmoreland
another great American victory it
corrupted the officer corps and appalled
the soldiers who by that time were
mostly draftees they were scurrying
around the jungle counting bodies which
was a pretty awesome and terrible thing
to do it had a real boomerang effect on
the military because it was like a
cancer it destroyed its soul
what was the military strategy of the
war Hackworth Westmoreland's idea was to
destroy the enemy's large battle
formations as in world war ii when
you've worn the enemy down you've won on
the field of battle that tells you that
we simply didn't understand the nature
of the war because the guerrilla was not
going to fight in that way the
guerrillas manner of fighting was to hit
and run so he could be alive to fight
another day he wasn't into these huge
stand up battles being operations
required a great number of resources a
great amount of logistics a great amount
of aircraft and a great amount of
artillery fire
Moshe Dayan who is the chief of staff of
the of the Israeli army came to Vietnam
and I interviewed him right after he had
spent two weeks with an American rifle
company of about a hundred men he said
that in one battle with a North
Vietnamese force of a couple hundred men
they fired more artillery over 25,000
rounds then he had fired in a whole
campaign that was the American Way of
fighting a war it was also terribly
expensive
each round was a hundred dollars if you
fired ten thousand rounds you've
probably gone through a million dollars
in one 15-minute fight and you've killed
seven enemy when you look at it from a
cost basis we are paying an enormous
amount to kill the enemy and we couldn't
sustain that kind of momentum and that
kind of expenditure for a long time it
was a failed tactic that never should
have been used we should have used the
same rules that mal was teaching that
sunsuit taught before to break up in
small elements and fight fire with fire
you only think about that economic you
pay a million dollars to kill seven
enemy soldiers that's you
it's not gonna work out well in the long
run no question had you been in charge
how would you have done things
differently Hackworth during my second
year in Vietnam I commanded a battalion
made up of conscripts down in the Delta
it was a battalion with very bad
leadership it did sustained 600
casualties in the six months before I
took over morale was low they called
themselves the Heartbreak Battalion
within 30 days they turned around and of
course we've covered this on steel my
soldiers hearts written by Hackworth
about this experience and we also
covered it in about face which he covers
that as well about this experience so
I'm moving a little bit quicker here we
fought like guerrillas we didn't fight
in these huge formations we broke up and
fought in small units of five or seven
people we fought at night we stole the
night from the enemy we ambushed
we didn't march in large formations and
expect to meet an opponent marching in
long from marching in large formations
we fought him using his very tactics his
very skills we tore a page out of mouths
book the proof of the pudding was six
months later that the battalion had only
lost 25 American soldiers it had killed
over 2,600 enemy soldiers and there were
no Vietcong in the area of operation
those soldiers proudly called themselves
the hardcore battalion and they were
hardcore but they were simply simple
draftees who didn't want to be there
question are you sure that was an acura
about it body count Hawk Werth yeah I
think that was an accurate body count
considering the inflated body count
techniques employed by the US military
at the time question wasn't the fight
because it's a little ironic that he
talks about how bad the body count is
and then he uses it yeah so he's kind of
getting called out on that a little bit
he should have just stuck to the fact
that there was no more Vietcong
operations in that area there used to be
X amount of an enemy attacks today now
there was zero sorry hak come on don't
worry I got you wasn't the fighting from
72 to 75 more like a convent more like
conventional warfare Hackworth it was
conventional warfare a guerrilla
campaign starts with a few people who
are dissatisfied they throw rocks at the
enemy they finally killed
enemy soldier and get a rifle they get
more rifles and they raid an armory and
they get more weapons and they build and
build up phase one of a guerrilla
campaign is individual sniping laying
booby traps and low scale conflict type
fighting the final goal phase
the final goal in phase four or five is
to move in brigades and divisions and
cores in a conventional formation and
that's the culmination of the war which
is interesting to think about when it's
like one of those situations where what
made you strong you leave behind right
it happens with companies all the time
you know this company starts off they're
small they're nimble they can adapt to
the market and then over time they get
so big they can't change anymore and
then some other company that was a
start-up is now small and nimble and can
take advantage of the the changes in the
market same thing happens unless you pay
attention unless you keep yourself
unless you enact decentralized command
and you can prevent it you can keep if
you if you start to centralize
everything what you have to get somewhat
more centralized when you grow like that
like one thing is in the military you
say well we've got decentralized command
well part of that part of the reason we
have that we can we can let people have
decentralized commanders because we have
the discipline training up front right
so once a company as a company grows if
you put discipline on them you can allow
them to still have decentralized command
and act very quickly you gotta have
trust in your subordinate leadership for
sure mmm - to be able to employ that
next question but the actual defeat of
the southern government was by the North
Vietnamese Regular Army that was hardly
a Vietcong victory was it Hackworth oh I
think that the architect of that general
tre was a Vietcong a southerner he was
the one that planned it there were a
number of Vietcong divisions for example
the 9th Vietcong division in the Delta
fought in the final battles as a regular
unit sure the majority were regular
forces from the north but they fought in
hit-and-run type operations they always
fought on the offensive that is
interesting to note is that a hundred
percent of all contacts when one guy
attacks another 85
were enemy initiated that means that
throughout the war the Americans were on
the defensive 85% of the time and the
enemy the Viet Cong and the North
Vietnamese was on the offensive you
can't win a war by being on the defense
you have to have the offensive power we
didn't have the initiative throughout
the war from beginning to end the
initiative rested in the hands of the
opponent the Viet Cong and the North
Vietnamese that's like um in jujitsu
when someone's just attacking and
attacking an AK and you're defending the
whole time you're going down I mean
eventually yeah you're going down
eventually and that was something that
that we definitely changed up in for my
last point when we were in Ramadi with
task unit bruiser whenever you're on
Patrol you're on defensive you're on the
defensive but once you set up a little
overwatch position and you're waiting
for the enemy Patrol well now you're
ambushing them so now you're on the
offense so I mean we weren't on offense
85% of the time but we were on offense a
lot of the time the boys were getting
out on offense and surprising the enemy
on a regular basis I mean probably more
than half the time because we were also
doing things where definitely we were on
the defensive
I mean it's offensive and defensive at
the same time when you're pushing
through uh when you're doing a clearance
operation you're on offense but you're
on defense because the enemy's waiting
for you you know so there's a little
dichotomy and doing that type of mission
but like doing a direct action mission
where you're gonna go and take down a
building where you think there's a bad
guy you're offensive when you get to
that target but while you're going to
the target you're waiting to get
ambushed you're waiting to get ambushed
that's what you're doing even though
you're scanning even though you're
looking for threats you're still waiting
to get ambushed you're waiting to roll
over an ID so you even feel like you're
on offense and we trained our guys to be
on offense if the reality is the first
shot in those situations is absolutely
gonna be fired by the enemy the ID is
gonna be initiated by the enemy and once
you do the raid to the raid itself
that's us being on offense right they're
in there sleeping or there they're not
expecting you to come and boom you blow
the door off and you enter their house
you're on offense yeah that's like
Foreman
and so you're saying before that before
that while you're going to the Tarkas
they like protected himself with
whatever does you're so unrelated like
let's say you're going for a bad guy
that guy X and he lives in the house you
know you're going to get him and when
you get there you're gonna surprise him
and he's not gonna be expecting you but
on the way there
that guy Z that guy am and bad guy F
have all set up ambushes on this road
not it may be completely disconnected
with my ex okay
but you are gonna have to go through the
ambushes that they've set and and they
don't care they'll set up that ambush
tonight no one comes okay cool setup
tomorrow no one comes well set up
tomorrow night yeah you only got to go
down that one road one time to get
ambushed yeah so you're on so when
you're going when you're when you're
moving through enemy territory you are
on defense yeah again that's not the
mindset we teach the mindset it's like
we're on offense where we're gonna go
get some the reality is the first shot
is gonna be most likely most likely
fired by the enemy most likely that's
the way it is and you know we did I mean
these big clearance bees big sector
clearances that we were doing the army
was doing the Marine Corps do and you're
like I said you're on offensive it's an
offensive push you're making the
initiative you're taking the initiative
and getting in there on a operational
level on a tactical level most likely
the enemy's gonna see you first
they're hidden they're hiding their two
rooms deep in a building they're there
waiting and they've got an ID buried in
the road yeah so so offensive is kind of
when you think about it is just like a
mindset kind of mainly to begin with
because it's so it's like a it's like a
forward leaning mindset I think an
offense means you offenses you should
strike first if you have the initiative
that's always when you have the
initiative that's office yeah when
you're reacting
that's defense yeah so like in your
situation that you're like so if I punch
you I was on offense right yeah if you
know me I just I was on defense so yours
was like a pump but I had you weren't
punching yeah interesting yeah it's it's
it's hard to
I guess really get the capture the
actual how you would explain that I
think the best I could do is what I just
said operationally you're on offense
right mean we're pushing into your
neighborhood yeah so that's essentially
so it's like just blow like this if you
had a bar you were the bouncer at a bar
and I had a beef with you
I showed up at your bar right right but
once I get there and get your face boom
you crack me you just went on offense
right or even better
while I'm going to your bar one of your
boys steps out of the alleyway cuz he
was waiting for me
cracks me the bottle in the back of the
head right gonna be ready for me like
you could yeah so now you got a whole
nother thing you gotta contend with so
there's different orders they better
kill me or kill me
you ain't deep into the earth scenario
I'm just saying try and be on offense
yeah that if you if you at least the
lesson to be learned there for me if
you're at least think about it at least
think about that you want to be on
offense and that was what was nice about
these you know a lot of the missions
that that we did in Iraq was like we
were surprising the enemy yeah but if
you can surprise the enemy you're on
offense yeah so yeah so like even like
you're looking back to your example your
your missions just the fact that you
initiated that capture kill mission
that's your offensive and defensive
movement yeah but just like when I'm
coming to the bar I gotta get to the bar
when we get there cuz I don't normally
get hit right so it's like throwing a
punch with that with that other hand up
and it's important to note that we would
teach our guys to have an offensive
mindset meaning when we you saw one of
our patrols on one of our vehicle
patrols or a foot patrol you'd see every
guy ready to engage the enemy yeah most
likely that first shots gonna come from
you know did that happen awesome knows
there's sometimes we don't on a patrol
guys would engage first or that that
could happen but most likely that that's
luck that's luck cuz most likely the
enemy is a little bit smarter they're
hiding in a you know when you're walking
think about when you walk down the
street think of how many windows there
are how many doors there are so now you
just walk down the street and how many
windows can you see two
300 right I mean if you're walking down
a city street you can see a hundred
windows let's say one of those windows
could have a bad guy in it and you can't
you're not gonna see him yeah he's gonna
see you first yeah
so check next question in April of 1975
during the fall of Saigon there were
some memorable images of American
helicopters taking off from the roof of
the American Embassy and dozens of South
Vietnamese trying to escape what were
your feelings when you saw those
pictures Hackworth I was heartbroken
when I saw the end come and the
helicopters airlifting people off the
embassy but at the same time in 1971
when I left Vietnam I said four years
from now the North Vietnamese will fly a
flag over this Capitol the reason I said
that and I was dead on to the month was
that I had been like a doctor feeling
the pulse of a dying patient and it was
obvious to me that this patient the
South Vietnamese government was on its
way down question was the April 1975
victory of victory for the people's
style of war Hackworth I think that the
victory in Vietnam introduced a new
phase of warfare where low intensity
conflict can eventually win question
what was what does the concept of a
people's war mean to you hackworth it's
the same thing that my forefathers
employed in 1776 we wanted independence
and we were willing to pay with our
lives all people want to be free and if
they have that anger inside them and the
ability to arm themselves and somebody
comes along and says hey I'm your leader
and I'm gonna show you how to do this
then the one guy who's trying to
suppress them is in trouble
question what are the key lessons to be
learned from the Vietcong success and
actually before we go into that question
if you think about you think about this
from a leadership perspective we all
wanted independence we all want to be
free and if somebody comes along and
tries to dictate to you how things are
gonna be that person is in trouble
right so as a leader if you try and
impose your will on people
look can you get away with it yes yes
does it work if you're in the you know
if you can fire someone or yes but to be
actually lead someone you can't just try
and impose your will on top of them
mm-hmm you can get them in the game too
next question how important was mass
mobilization to the success of the
Vietcong Hackworth if you're going to
fight a war today you're going to need
your whole nation behind you either as
fighters or supporters or carriers it's
no longer the act of a few soldiers
fighting on a sunny Hill waving swords
at one another warfare is now the
employment of the complete population
the Vietcong took on two superpowers
France and then the United States and
they couldn't have done it on a
shoestring they needed to mobilize
everything within their nation and they
needed to get as much outside support as
possible at the end the war became
almost a conventional war one of the
things that bothers me is that the
Americans who are now trying to rewrite
history of what actually happened say we
won all the battles but we lost the war
but we didn't win all the battles we
lost most of the battles this is really
this is really critical this is a very
important thing to think about the
reason they've come up with this very
bad rationale is because of the American
way of keeping score in the old American
Way of conventional warfare if you're
king of the mountain at the end of the
day you've won the battle but to the
Vietcong it wasn't who held the ground
it was what kind of punishment you
inflicted on your enemy
the Vietcong and North Vietnamese were
willing to pay an easy or easy ratio of
10 to 1 if you fought him and you lost
one soldier and he lost 10 he walked
away saying I was the winner
there's the mentality that you have to
understand and that's why you have to be
willing to kill and you have to be
willing to die if you're gonna go to war
that's why right there hmm question can
parallels be drawn between Afghanistan
and Vietnam between the Vietcong war
against the Americans and the Mujahideen
war success against the Soviets
Hackworth
absolutely there's no question that the
that there are sharp parallels between
the Afghan
and the war in Vietnam the fighters
there were freedom fighters they were
trying to rid themselves of communism
they were supported by an outside
country this time the USA who poured
billions of dollars into that war they
tried to win by using an enormous amount
of firepower said they being the
Russians the Russians tried to win by
using an enormous amount of firepower
conventional tactics against the Search
and Destroy operation a high degree of
Technology all the mistakes that the
Soviets made in Afghanistan the
Americans made in Vietnam and the French
made in Indochina no one looked back on
the lessons learned did the Soviets
learn anything from America's experience
in Vietnam Hackworth from my analysis of
the war I'd say very little they tried
to win the war by using firepower by
bombing them back to the Stone Age
through the use of American provided
Stinger missiles and by mounting machine
guns in high mountains and firing down
on aircraft they made the price so heavy
for the Soviets of in terms of costs
that they blinked first and got out
again they used an incredible number of
mines and booby traps creating a great
number of Soviet casualties the Soviet
units did that did well there were
special units led by people who
understood that form of wealth warfare
but their conventional infantry was
exactly the same as the American
conventional infantry in Vietnam or the
French conventional infantry in
Indochina question why did the Soviets
fail to learn from the American and
French mistakes Hackworth I think it is
a military mindset we don't want to go
back and look at the past we're in such
a hurry to get where we're going there's
a certain amount of military arrogance
the older I get the more I realize how
we never study the past and try to learn
from it we just stumble along and make
the same mistakes we're doomed to do
that until people wake up and with the
military mind I'm not sure we'll ever
wake up
gotta keep your ego in check
gotta learn from the past 100% correct
question is there anything about
guerrilla warfare which is new to this
century hackworth well a number of
things are new the amount of firepower
that the insurgent employs and uses the
use of booby traps and mines the ability
to communicate via electronic
communications one of the problems
that's always hampered the guerrillas
getting the word out in the days of old
it was done by messengers which took
days and hours today a general has very
sharp communications out in Somalia
general adid had little portable radios
to talk to his soldiers very low
frequency the American CIA's intercept
devices are all high frequency they
couldn't listen to what the man was
saying they didn't learn a thing
question how frightened was the average
American conscript faced with all these
obstacles and the skill of the enemy
hackworth the average American soldier
going into battle in Vietnam carried a
whole pack full of fear mainly because
he wasn't trained properly back in the
States the training base was just off
they were preparing for World War two
not for insurgency warfare
so the lad received 16 weeks of training
was flung into Vietnam generally in a
unit that was never kept together but it
was always filled up by the individual
replacement system as a result there was
no real strong cohesion no teamwork in
the unit and this is something that SLA
Marshall talked about in men against
fire the soldier was like an orphan
thrown into a family but a family that
was not solidly put together as a result
his fear level behind because of the
uncertainty of what he was going into
the typically the typical kid who went
to Vietnam was black 21 percent of all
soldiers were blocked and the Hispanics
and the whites were from others the
other side of the railroad tracks if he
went to a good university like Brown
University or something you'd find you
didn't find yourself carrying an m16
rifle and V
mom you did it Clinton you got out of
the war it was very unfair the poor
working classes were the ones that
carried out the war effort but they're
made of tough stuff because their whole
life required tough stuff once they were
provided with the leadership the proper
leadership that raw material did a hell
of a job but it didn't make the fear go
away when you're playing in that kind of
a lethal Super Bowl the possibility of
dying and coming home in a rubber bag is
always lingering in the back of your
head regardless of how courageous you
are you will still have fear but if you
have competent leadership that you have
confidence in and if you're well-trained
you can get the job done it's my theory
that the better trained you are the more
natural courage you have because you
have a belief in yourself that's all
important stuff the better trained you
are the more natural courage you have
keep that in mind also the raw material
just give me some good leadership and
we'll make something happen
continuing our soldiers weren't well
trained and in the main they weren't
well led but the longer the soldiers
stayed there the more experienced he
became and the more confident he became
the uncertainty was dispelled he knew
what to expect but the fear would never
go away you know you can never go near a
battlefield without having those
butterflies in your stomach question
what frightened your soldiers most
Hackworth I think it was the uncertainty
once they got into a unit and knew they
were well led knew that their commander
loved them and cared for them and would
not throw them into harm's way unless
absolutely necessary
their main fear was just that
uncertainty that came from the mines and
booby traps and it's a psychological
thing I've walked down trails and I've
said to myself a sniper has me in his
sights you
play those mind games with yourself I've
had that kind of experience where I saw
a guy where I saw a guy looking through
his rifle looking at me perfectly at
what we call a six o'clock sight picture
and he's going to squeeze and you spot
yourself going down good leadership
dispels all those kinds of mind games
question there are all these images of
American soldiers walking around smoking
pot beads around their necks singing
rock songs clearly the morale of the
American troops broke down Hackworth the
morale of the American army
disintegrated the longer the war went on
we went there with a professional army
that was well led by very fine combat
leaders most of whom were World War two
or Korea experienced I'm talking about
senior NCOs and officers they had a lot
of battle experience and were high
quality people and they were badly used
from the beginning they were traded out
so we lost the noncommissioned officer
corps almost straightaway within the
first 18 months of the war after that
there was no unit cohesion every 365
days you had a new unit you had no
institutional memory I know this might
seem obvious but you got to keep people
together when you get a good team you
got to keep them together you got to
keep them working together no one
remembered what happened last month and
they kept repeating the same mistakes
again and again and again
the Americans were in Vietnam for eight
years and there were no leaders at the
top willing to raise hell and demand
that the training be hard and amend the
standards be high no one wanted to shake
things up in a very very unpopular war
now the finest thing you can do for any
young soldier is be mean as hell with
him and whack him in the head when he
doesn't do something correctly make
certain that he knows his job and knows
how to do it right because if he does it
right he'll do it right on the
battlefield but the whole training and
leading leadership system were asking
how can we resolve this dissent
morale problem we can resolve it by
getting them R&R delivering cold beer
and coke and ice cream at night and hot
food this is what the generals mentality
was instead of kicking them in the ass
and making them do things right screw on
their steel pot carry their weapon and
clean up their ammo get rid of their
love beads and not smoke dope when I
took over my battalion in a delta it was
grass all over the place before I'd go
out with my battalion I'd shake
everybody down I boot people in the but
who even smoked cigarettes because you
could smell tobacco a mile away you
could see the light from a cigarette a
couple miles away in my unit you didn't
smoke anything and you certainly didn't
smoke grass it was just a question of
discipline if you had good leadership
and provide a disciplined designed not
to harass but to keep people alive the
soldiers would react so critical
distinction they're not talking about
discipline just just design to harass
people and do things for no good reason
but discipline that's actually there to
keep people alive continuing if they
didn't have that they would react the
other way what we saw between 1965 and
1973 when the last US forces went out
was a total disintegration it was an
organization that didn't have proper
boundaries and didn't have people
insisting on those boundaries they were
an army of hippies and they didn't have
discipline had the war continued for a
few more years we were seeing at the end
by 1973 units refusing to fight well
we'd have seen a whole army that refused
to fight because it was a most unpopular
war and soldiers were saying what am I
doing here
my politicians want me out my family
wants me out and there's no purpose in
being here this does not affect my
country's security all I am is a pawn is
stupid war they were an army of hippies
and didn't have discipline had the war
continued for a few more years we're
seeing at the end 19th by 1973 units
refusing
fight well we'd seen in hole we'd see
we'd have seen a whole army that refused
to fight because it was a most unpopular
war and the soldiers were saying what am
I doing here
my politicians want me out my family
wants me out and there's no purpose in
me being here this does not affect my
country security all I am is a pawn in a
stupid war I mean okay first of all
obviously we're not talking about
everyone every soldier every marine
every service member in Vietnam that was
acting that way clearly there was people
still doing heroic things and serving to
the best of their ability but he's
making a broad general statement that if
we saw 1973 some units that were saying
hey we don't want to fight then if you
would have continued down that
trajectory you eventually been saying
hey wait a second there'd be a lot more
to units that would be saying that next
how did your soldiers particularly your
fresh recruits cope with not knowing who
the enemy was
hackworth when a soldier would arrive in
Vietnam badly trained from the USA not
prepared for the war my procedure was
that each unit formed their own training
program at Division level the young
recruit would go through this training
up to two weeks in his particular in his
particular area of operations for
example looking after your feet in the
Mekong Delta
keeping your ammo dry and things of this
nature after they finished that division
level training they would come to a unit
normally I would talk to my soldiers
welcome them to the unit assign them to
a rifle company my standard operating
procedure was to assign a young recruit
to an old soldier in the same foxhole
that soldier would be his buddy
a veteran would get a green recruit or
fresh meat as they called them and he
would take that new guy and pass his
knowledge to him question were your
soldiers ever reluctant to fight
Hackworth I had the ability to motivate
people even though a guy might be a
pacifist in a few days he was hunting
for Charlie
I never had a problem in terms of
getting soldiers to fight question were
you ever frightened can you remember a
moment when you were frightened
Hackworth I spent eight years on
battlefields as a soldier and I'm sure
that there was that there aren't very
many minutes of those eight years that I
wasn't frightened it's something that
lives in your stomach it's just churning
all the time as the bullet starts
snapping in the intensity of combat
increases that churning increases but
it's always there as long as you're in a
dangerous situation you've got it and
you're carrying it with you on your back
question did your soldiers have any
compunction about shooting civilians on
the chance that they were Vietcong
Hackworth I think the average American
soldier perceived the enemy as but for
the grace of God their go eye and they
were reluctant to shoot somebody unless
they knew they were the enemy but if the
guy were coming at him at night if the
guy were walking in an area he shouldn't
be in and had weapons or something like
that the way I trained my soldiers was
to react automatically don't get the
thinking process going when you see a
right cross come at you block it with
your left hand and go with a right hook
I never had problems with soldiers being
reluctant to fight of course this is
this is different then you know the SLA
marshal report of people not wanting to
fight and it's also you know I I say
this in sometimes people freaked out
about it when I say don't think right
stop thinking hey your alarm clock goes
off in the morning don't think you just
get up and you do what you're supposed
to do
ouu you're supposed to work out don't
think about it mmm
just go do it and that's what he's
saying for a more important situation oh
there's an enemy threat don't think
about it do what you're supposed to do
yeah
would it surprise you to know that the
chief concierge at the Continental Hotel
Saigon stop hotel was in fact working
for the Vietcong Hackworth it wouldn't
surprise me at Tet of 68 the secretary
of to the commanding general of the US
forces in Vietnam general Westmoreland
was found holding an ak-47 with the
whole Vietnamese apparatus I never once
trusted a Vietnamese I never trusted a
Vietnamese general I never allowed a
Vietnamese inside my camp my firebase if
I were going to meet a Vietnamese
Colonel I would meet him outside my
firebase because I didn't trust him I
assumed everybody was vehicle question
and these are the people you were meant
to be fighting for hackworth that's
right and that was my attitude the
soldiers from the 9th division hated the
South Vietnamese soldiers more than they
did the Vietcong so what he's saying
right there is I'm gonna read that again
my soldiers from the 9th division hated
the South Vietnamese soldiers more than
they did the Vietcong that's a horrible
situation they saw them coming and going
out they saw them going out on
operations and not beating the enemy but
avoiding the enemy they called it search
and avoid where it was supposed to be
Search and Destroy my battalion could go
all the way through the same area and
come back bloodied and battered that
really got to my guys I was walking the
perimeter one night I used the British
system of stand 2 in the evening where
everybody was at their post with a
weapon ready to go just as the Sun was
going down one of my sniper said sir
how's the body count today and I said
not so good we only had eight or nine
for the day for the battalion and he
said well I'll get you two more before I
could stop him he took out a sniper
rifle I looked down at the end of the
weapon to see you where it was pointed
and it was pointed at two South
Vietnamese soldiers guarding a bridge
about 40 meters from my perimeter I
knocked the weapon up before he had a
chance to scream squeeze off around this
is the attitude of a lot of soldiers
they didn't like the South Vietnamese
because they didn't pull their weight
question why did massacres occur in
Vietnam hackworth well the big massacre
was me Lai Lieutenant William Calley and
captain Medina were the principal
characters involved in that act why did
they have that occur it occurred for a
number of reasons the soldiers were
frustrated they were mainly frustrated
because of mines and booby traps and
because they could never find the enemy
they were just tripping through
minefields and seeing their mates blown
away
never grabbing hold of the enemy and
getting into a real fight then there's a
lot of people in a village and then
insanity takes over and they just start
blowing human beings away it's also
about bad leadership lieutenant Calley
had gone through Officer Candidate
School he'd gone through three separate
courses was found wanting in leadership
and two of them and had been recycled
instead of being booted out the military
was into a numbers game and didn't want
to have a try high attrition rate for
their officers they kept recycling
someone until they graduated so here's a
guy who never should have been trusted
more than an army PFC ends up a
lieutenant he's with a platoon of
soldiers who extremely frustrated
because of mines and booby traps and he
doesn't have the leadership ability to
control them to say stop that fire
I think massacres occur when you don't
have strong leadership when you don't
have soldiers who are extremely
well-trained and well disciplined and
well controlled by their leaders that's
what happened all those components fell
apart
and I think the book that we covered on
the meal I mascar actually gave even
better details I mean obviously gave
better details because it's a full book
but I really was one of the key things I
remembers I remember how the
intelligence escalated it escalated and
I'll tell you something else he's saying
that you know that lieutenant Calley
couldn't stop them
lieutenant Calley led that massacre he
led the masker wasn't him saying oh I
can't get control the guys know he was
actually doing the massacre and they
were they were actually following them
and that wraps up that that wraps up the
interview was kind of abrupt ending I
don't know why it's so abrupt I looked
around to see if there was anything I
was missing but that's that's how they
that's how the interview ends but I
wanted to go to from there I wanted to
just grab a couple sections out of the
Vietnam primer again this is the book
that that hackworth wrote with s la
Marshall when they got back for when
they got back from this toward Vietnam
was a few months long and they went and
talked debriefed all kinds of people and
again there's all kinds of tactical
level lessons in here I mean like real
tactical doubling security contending
with the jungle security on the trail
the company in movement field
intelligence I mean there's the
defensive perimeter it's just very it's
also a very short book it's not even 100
pages long and like I said if you want
to get this if you're in the military
you might be able to use this if you're
leading a if you're a platoon leader you
probably get some decent lessons learned
out of this but this isn't one of those
books that translates directly to
business because it's actually not it's
not about leadership it's about the
tactics of an infantry platoon an
infantry company so but that being said
of course there are some there are some
lessons and what's interesting to me as
also as I found these leadership lessons
they're not just leadership lessons
beyond being leadership lessons
there's a lot of lessons here for you as
a person for me as a person and you
start taking the leadership lessons from
Vietnam primer and applying them to
yourself I think you could see a lot of
crossover starting from a leadership
perspective though here we go
Vietnam primer back to the book our
mistakes in Vietnam are neither new nor
startling they are not something we can
blame on the mysteries of warfare they
are the same problems that have been
haunting small unit commanders since
before Gideon in peace or war these
errors spell the difference between
professionalism and mediocrity many
young leaders enchanted by the Hollywood
image of war approached combat with the
good guy versus the bad guy attitude but
there is no similarity between what John
Wayne gets away with on the screen and
the hot hard facts of a firefight a
small unit leader in combat cannot
afford to have a film heroes
devil-may-care attitude toward training
discipline and basic soldiering in the
recipe for battle victory well led and
disciplined soldiers are the main
ingredient soldiers who have been
conditioned through training to react by
habit when confronted when confronted
with the searing realities of engagement
the habits learned in training good or
bad are the same habits that move the
soldier in combat a leader then must
ensure that each of his soldiers is well
trained and has developed good habits
habits so deeply ingrained through
correct teaching and intensive practice
that even under the pressure of fear and
son danger each soldier automatically
will do the right thing check
continuing there is no magic formula or
sweat 'less solution by which one can
achieve this goal there's no there's no
hacking hmm leaders may approach
training for combat only with intense
dedication accepting as gospel the
timeless truth that better trained men
live longer on the battlefield no
military unit is ever completely trained
there will always be a weak area that
requires additional time and effort the
wise commander uses all available time
to train his unit he never says good
enough leaders must accept the old but
absolute maxim the more sweat on the
training field the less blood on the
battlefield
combat is too serious a business to
permit easy excuse of even one mistake
never quit checking check everything all
the time
weapons for cleanliness aid men for
supplies centuries for alertness and the
camp for fields and sanitation another
weakness among junior leaders is the
inaccurate report of the estimate of the
situation estimates are many times
either so greatly exaggerated or so
watered down that they are not
meaningful to the next higher commander
who must make critical decisions as to
troop employment and allocation of
combat power the confusion and noise of
the battlefield are two reasons why
faulty estimates are made over
emotionalism and the sense of the drama
are others
these factors coupled with the judgment
of an impulsive commander who feels that
he must say something on the radio even
if it is wrong are the crux of the
problem
commanders must report the facts as they
see them on the battlefield if they
don't know the situation they must just
say that and again those are just a
couple little lessons learned out of
Vietnam primer and you know I think one
of the things like I said there's a lot
of things that you can take from what
Hackworth talks about and we talks about
leadership and you can actually apply it
to yourself you can apply it to your
personal life and some of the things
that you just said think about some of
these our mistakes are nothing new or
startling think about that most of the
time most of the time think about this
most of the time when you make a mistake
it's something that you already knew you
actually know you're making the mistake
when you're making it here's another
thing he says errors spell the
difference between professionalism and
mediocrity it's the little things it's
the little mistakes that you make next
thing you think says discipline soldiers
are the main ingredient in victory well
guess what the main ingredient in
victory in your life is yeah
all day he says there's no magic formula
or sweat list solution by which one can
achieve their goals I think he just said
there's no there is no shortcut there is
no hack hmm there's no sweat list
solution you you're gonna have to work
then he says this no military unit is
ever completely trained guess what
neither are you neither am i there is
always weakness to work on always a lot
of them
he says this in Vietnam primer combat is
too serious a business to permit easy
excuse of even one mistake now think
about this okay
combats too serious of business why is
that it's because you can die but guess
what we're all gonna die we're all gonna
die so why would we why would we allow
ourselves to make easy easy excuses why
would you allow that hmm combats life
and death so is life so you shouldn't
allow yourself these easy excuses and in
the last section that that eat daddy
talks about that I read it can
absolutely be applied it can absolutely
absolutely be applied he says another
weakness common among junior leaders is
the inaccurate reporting of the estimate
of the situation they are either so
exaggerated or will so watered-down that
they are not meaningful now again if you
apply this to yourself what you realize
is that you got these junior leaders
that they're lying to the chain of
command I mean they're exaggerating or
they're watering things down but they're
basically lying to the chain of command
and how does that translate to us we lie
to ourselves mmm that's how it translate
to us we lie to ourselves we don't tell
ourselves the way things really are and
when we do that then we can't fix our
problems hmm if we can't fix our
problems we're not going to improve so
we have to be truthful to ourselves I
have to be truthful to myself you have
to be truthful to yourself you have to
stop rationalizing stop making excuses
stop telling yourself little water down
assessments of where you're really at
tell yourself the truth
so that you can get where you want to go
you can be who you want to be you could
be who you should be who you should be
when you do what you know you should do
when you pay attention to the little
things when you implement discipline
true and unflinching and unmitigated
discipline in your life when you stop
when you stop trying to find a sweat
list solution when you look for
weaknesses to work on when you allow no
easy excuses and all that starts when
you stop lying to yourself then you stop
lying to yourself that's when you can
become who you know you should be when
you tell yourself the truth about where
you are so you can make sure you are in
the right place and if you're not in the
right place then you can get yourself on
the path to get there the path of
discipline the path of hard work and the
path of truth
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
so echo Charles speaking of the path
from the path the path of truth mm-hmm
but open to any suggestions you may or
may not have on how we can get on that
path and then go ahead and stay on that
path stay on the path
yeah I feel like more and more of us are
on the path it's what I feel like you
know at the roll call at the roll call
that we just got done which was an event
if you don't know for military first
responders law enforcement paramedics
fire fighters there was a lot of people
there that are straight up on the path
right now legitimately on the path you
know yeah and it's one of those deals
where you know like when you hear a
certain story and then you know about
someone you like like dang that's
impressive and then you hear it again
and again and then again and then you're
like okay you know I'm kind of used to
it
I don't feel like I've gotten used to
this at all because everyone's stories
kind of different you know so it kind of
exposes this element of like
like just immense individuality of a
person you know so it's it's kind of
like I don't know it's like I don't know
maybe like your kids birthday or
something that happens over and over
again but never gets old you know kind
of that kind of situation um there was a
guy he was like and he just told me this
while we were listening to you guys dude
you just sue and you just right in the
middle of it just kind of in my ear and
he's like dude I lost 70 pounds yeah
geez guys were just guys and girls
females boys and girls men and women
we're walking up to me and like showing
me pictures yeah hey this is what I look
like
13 months ago no I've lost 38 pounds or
whatever yeah awesome I got promoted
yeah it's it's it's awesome
so yes you are correct there's a lot of
people on the path
kids everything kids ever oh yeah oh
yeah people and I made little videos for
kids yeah me too I was looking at videos
kids kids doing pull-ups it's doing
jiu-jitsu the warrior kids straight up
on the path
knowing the knowing the Gettysburg
Address Hey look at this kid
look at my son he knows the Gettysburg
Address he's six look at my daughter
that's six pull-ups right there you know
you know how many she could do last year
zero yeah
you see what I'm saying yes you do you
think it's gonna get crowded on the back
no it'll get wider maybe the path gets
wider it's wise everyone's kind of on
their own path but they're just a
unified yeah oh there's common ground on
the path yeah there's a silicon you know
I mean on a fundamental level actually
there's there's immense commonality down
there but the path is big enough to
maintain it's not gonna be there's not
gonna be a traffic jam on the path no
it's not yeah you know the more people
have a path the faster it goes yeah more
momentum yeah yeah shoot so all right
well weird how you take leadership
principles and apply them to yourself
yeah yeah so it's almost like I won't
lie to yourself think about that because
you think about the little lies you tell
yourself oh yeah they de lies oh so long
time ago my my mom was like overweight I
didn't know I mean I guess I knew that
no no when you're a little kid you don't
know you justice huh
and my and then so she got on the path
back in the day inch and she lost a
bunch of weight and my dad said hey you
know what I'm gonna get your mom for her
birthday I was like what he's like a
mirror a full size mirror cuz she lost a
bunch of weight good you know whatever
no and I was like cool you know stuff
whatever furniture was a furniture good
you know whatever good good job dad
whatever you know kind of then I kind of
thought about it and I'm thinking about
it more now it's like man you know what
that you know what that says that says
that like you know she was like
overweight and she was a sick for my dad
to know that you know and to take action
like that means that he knew that she
was in a way
and one way or another avoiding the
mirror yeah and well I would say
straight-up avoiding it but she just
didn't want to see herself in the mirror
yeah you said the same thing I said I
guess I said a little bit of different
way but she didn't want to see yourself
in the mirror right like if if you have
a and you're gonna think about it sure
you have a mirror in the bathroom and
it's sort of it but like I don't know
where else do we have mirrors right like
I don't know in the bedroom or something
you know what girls get ready I know I'm
compared to my crap situation I know I
have like the mirror in the bathroom
medicine cabinet that's it yeah yeah I
guess my Dino what you're right cuz both
my daughters my older daughters had
mirrors in their room yeah I love
sitting right get ready yeah right right
you get the outfit I don't know mirror
but for a girl I don't know again I'm
just totally like thinking of my
situation so and yeah so I kind of
thinking back I'm like dang we only had
the mirror in the bathroom anyway so for
that to be the case for a mirror to be a
good gift where your dad's gonna tell
you like gift it kind of indicates that
you don't like it cool it's like oh yeah
so anyway the point is like yeah we do
kind of lie to ourselves even if we
don't think we're necessarily lying or
it's like you don't want to admit
certain things it's the omission yeah
you lying by omission like I'm not even
gonna look at myself here for this whole
subject my life or whatever it's like it
yeah it's like lie by omission like if
you don't do Jiu Jitsu yeah like like
know if you don't know you wonder if you
don't do Jiu Jitsu one day let's say
there's let's say there's in a month
there's four days that you didn't do
jujitsu three of those could have been
legitimate days where you're
legitimately for whatever reason
couldn't do Jitsu one of those days
might have been predicated on a lie that
you told yourself right yeah right like
I just don't have time today
yeah when what you really did was you
extended some work yeah an extra cuz I
so there's a weird time there's a word
time thing that happens what you did to
like hey class starts it start the class
starts at 4:30 or class starts at like
hey I'm gonna roll at 5:30
the guys are everyone's training at 6:00
right hey we're doing noogie at 6:00
well if I get caught up in something
mysteriously and all of a sudden its 604
at my house uh you know what I won't
even get there until 6:20 or 6:15 by the
time I get changed
you know the guys will probably be done
yeah you told yourself a bunch of Lies
well there I would say because there's
not nothing though this is a my hook is
called the jujitsu window okay like
there cuz there is not like the gym well
the like it that I should have said this
that the lie came earlier the like oh
yeah it was like I should really get
this done right now yeah ya know you
could get that done when you get home
later but you just you just extended
that window cuz you wanted to shut that
you did to window on yourself right
right yeah happens and that window is
like that's a weird psychological area
to be in because it's cooking I call it
at home I call it the jujitsu window
that's why it's kind of like when my
will be like hey can you can you just go
later it's like no you can't go there's
a window and it's super super narrow
just like I said when it's 604 and
you're supposed to be there at 6:00 is
that because here's the factors one
everyone will be either finishing up or
late in the round yeah yeah you four
you'll get one roll so kind of the lid
the later you show up the less training
you're gonna get the less training you
get the less worth it is to to get
dressed and get all your stuff together
and go I'm not saying it's gonna be not
worth it but it becomes less and less
worth it all right so there's that and
then there's like the social things I
call you the guy that shows up on the
last round we retired what are you doing
dude you know there's kind of like a
stigma with that and when some when
somebody says that to me I'm like I'll
it I just got done working I came here
as quickly as I could
yeah I'll tell you what I'll do 35
burpees right now yeah then we can train
you yeah
and that's of course that's not because
because that's not always the case I
mean with you I can't marry limber
actually done that before yeah that in
just your answer there kind of indicated
like that's never happened to you has
this like kind of thing oh there's
there's one you know big Eric yeah yeah
yeah it'll be like oh you're showing up
I'm like bro he also did like one round
no we don't care I made another thing
you'll say is if he's done anything else
that day he'll tell you about it like
like hey I went ran stairs this morning
I'm like that's cool
I squatted did sprints went surfing and
now I'm here to Train
what yeah yeah but nonetheless do you
see wind it's real you know because
you'll you let me have meat and I don't
mean this you know in a hostile way how
come sometimes when the jiu-jitsu class
starts let's say it let's say we're
gonna train at 11 how come sometimes you
show up at like 11 48 seems like your
window is way just off alignment I don't
know let's call it a Sunday right we all
know what time we start training right
yeah and then sometimes you come rolling
in I mean you want to talk about you you
like hey we you know you're 15 minutes
late these guys from you done I'm I'm an
hour and a half yes brown walking and
you're rolling in like Boeing up to me
yeah well I'm gonna bullet regarding and
of course I'm not gonna be saying hey
you know you're showing up late and I'm
kind of tired no I'm gonna say okay we
showing up we'll do what we got to do
yeah you know you know what it is okay
because you know I have no idea I have
no idea how someone could be snowing
that all of his training partners that
wanna train with him are there at 10
o'clock or at 11 o'clock and that
individual decides hey I'll just show up
at 11:48 and call it good on Sunday the
normal routine has always been I come at
noon for Greg trains noogie train okay
okay and and then I over two three four
years you've shown up at that time see
me in a ball of sweat you know 12 rounds
deep ya know if you if you remember
correctly there there are times that all
come it'll be me you and Andy just going
around robbing there will be those times
but you're look at the amount of times
that Andy and I have done well is very
large number yeah I know but here this
is why though so it has to do with like
my whole overall life scheduling see
saying so noon is the best time and I
get to create a train with Greg and you
know all this stuff and then you'll text
me like the day before saying hey we're
going to freaking can't oh I'm like okay
you got a hardcore crazy schedule I need
to call your sister you gonna put in
your calendar the day before I call I'll
text and iam like and be like hey I'm
heading to the gym in 15 minutes he's
like I'm on my way
look Wednesday night Thursday Sunday
morning whatever bro what if okay what
if you and Andy had trip plans to train
at tan and I text you hey let's train at
1:30
yeah I'd say no be here at 10:00 why not
1:30 cuz because we're not training then
we're training at 10:00 yeah but I still
don't understand why 1:30 here you train
that's what time we train
well what about 1/3 what's the
difference we got other things to do but
oh there you go we have other things to
do so I had like obligations ok this is
normal this is not like a random thing
that happens this is the steady state
for years yeah 11:48 early yeah I do I
do I am 14 we come in and you see sweat
yeah are you a little bit bummed out yes
why I do not adjust your schedule why
don't you calendar yourself well because
I it's weird it's like that mother it's
all I'm on this like psychological Pat
like you're lying to yourself
no no I'm so not lying to yourself
Hackworth says no I'm gonna lyin to you
so I'm gonna go ahead and assume that I
am lying to myself so I'm gonna find it
in anger
admit it to myself but this is what it
feels lighter comes the law like all
week I do whatever whatever whatever
right in the training so on Sunday my
normal route like habitual kind of
routine on Sunday is a noon training so
everything before noon that I do and
have to do or whatever that's just sort
of in place it doesn't take much mental
work but then if you're like texting me
the night before saying hey tan I'm like
oh man kind of in my mind I'm already
kind of committed to the noon to myself
though brow head bitch really
this is just the live is like a whole
conspiracy run against yourself or
consider this like okay so let's X one
two three four things I got to do before
noon and then when I get back I don't
know that's the thing but they are their
time they are time sensitive in this
sense that I do have to do them so if I
plan to do them before training now I
got a shift all that other stuff for
like you know and there's other people
involved all this stuff anyway that's
usually the case but looking for oh no
one's gonna fall you down the path is
kind of and now they I'm not so funny
but this is the truth this is this bad
this is this good actually at the end is
good so I'll have a lot of see this
situation yeah I'm telling you and
you're like laughing at me and telling
me I'm lying to myself that this
situation goes on in a lot of ways with
me with everyone but yeah but you're
gonna confess I'm confessing this so
when I tell you like out loud stuff and
some of the stuff is like I just start
telling you in just your face and like
try know the answer it I know already
and this is one of those things where
before I got into it I was like for real
committed to it like this is like true
that's how it is and this is the reason
and sometimes I'll come train with you
guys you know when I do all this work to
shift it around but if I were to just
shift it around and be like that's the
new schedule like I could do it it's in
America you know just I just realized
this very good a a very a very solid
quality I'd have talked about I always
talk about people like everyone's
allergic to criticism like everyone
hates getting criticized like you tell
me to do something different 140 talking
about yeah you're actually very open to
criticism and I think part of it is
because well maybe it's because when I
criticize you I'm not telling you like
hey do it
you I'm just saying like hey you tell me
what your reason isn't we'll figure out
if you're lazy different idealize
yourself or not over on my side of the
table over here uh-huh
we think we suspect we're suspected of
them of the statement
yeah very suspect so there it is anyways
what the the thing is maybe we can
adjust that maybe we can we we can snuff
out that lie we can find all the truth
is the truth is you should be training
with your training your normal training
partners yeah on the Sunday whenever
that whenever that that that agreed-upon
time is out there $10 nice eleven
o'clock nine ten o'clock is nice yeah
you know it's nice to hold gym what do
you mean the whole gym I just empty oh
yeah just just getting after it
yeah yeah that is remember remember when
we first opened this gym up and you're
like hey we got new before the mats were
all even in and you were like there's
new mats downstairs remember that yeah
and then there was still sleep I wanted
to Testament that's the new mattress
yeah and we're rolling we're rolling for
a bit like pretty long as far as two
guys rolling yeah and then you're like
dang man must be like goodness like we
just had the whole deal you know yeah
this very nice just sure that there's a
nice thing to have
speaking of the yes okay everyone we're
gonna do Jesus that's what we're doing
if you're on the path or looking or
interested if if the path is right for
you kind of situation if someone's geek
curious and it is yeah yes and you're
doing you just say you're gonna need
Agee because you can't just just do nogi
as tempting as that might be it is
tempting you some geek it's tempting
until you say or do you want to be so
good in one thing and this being lost
you know it's something that's so close
yeah and they both complement each other
yes they really do yeah I did a bunch of
rounds of ghee in at peak PMMA yeah it
was good did some good rounds good did
you did two players out there yeah it's
some good times but it was all geek
as Oggy I was like I told JP I'm like
hey I'm not bringing Aggie and he's like
hey just bring your belt and and I'll
get Yugi if you need it just for the
class then you can roll Guinot he
afterwards so I'm like okay cool
mm-hm and then I put the giel and I had
a geek get his one of his geez pants
were too tight I couldn't move my legs
mm-hmm was it super ugly no it was an
origin key no there's all the warrior DS
the knight wait ones yeah
anyway long story short got a bunch of
good Ronson always fond of Nicky so yeah
you're gonna need a key if you're on the
path and you start jujitsu or you've
already started you're just you're gonna
need a gate what kind do you need that's
the question that's always a question
you get a origin geez not a question not
anymore
No there it is boom question answered or
Jinky go to origin main comm that's
where you get your key or made in
America
all made in America from beginning to
end
mm-hmm there's some rash guards too for
noogie so boom get them both and get
your jujitsu established did you say
rash guards yes okay you got rash guards
and other what do you call this normal
clothes normal clothes that's what did I
say a pair of one day you like that's oh
that's that's no not not not the thing
to say no no I said up i I said apparel
to clear it with you you said cool no
fashion no yeah even though he he's he
has one piece in the fashion he's got a
whole art thing going on yeah respect
you know his father-in-law Joe what were
you doing oh yeah we were taking the
picture at the immersion camp yeah and
he started like Pete started getting all
hey you come over here a little bit hey
we need and was really taking some
artistic control the situation instead
of Joyce and here comes the big artist
guy coming out yes oh he's got more than
just a pinky in there
yeah old pinkies at a minimum well good
because not everybody's like you and
some people they like that fashion
element
I was gonna talk to Pete about this so
Pete he's listening right now it was
actually a very accurate statement when
I said when we had this conversation
before my
ultimate goal of fashion is to make no
impression yeah and I guess that's
completely the wrong thing to do
yes sir it is but that's my thing
if you I want my clothing to look in
such a way that when you look at me you
just see you know what you see what but
really normal okay just don't feel
normal like just normal clothes like you
wouldn't be able to say I bet that guy
now the exception that I have to that I
got the victory mmm a t-shirt that's
your thing yeah
and the reason I have that is because I
have a bunch of them and I just wear the
same thing every day yeah so I have that
little thing but if you see me traveling
when I'm not wearing t-shirt I knew we
were in something were you you just
think oh this is just a normal person
you know this person has no nothing
right
no thing yeah well so if you we I don't
want to call this a mistake but here's
the thing that makes that it almost like
an antiquated kind of scenario okay
because you're like I'm my goal is you
said my goal is to be normal whatever if
that's your goal your your is not to
make a statement right you know you know
that's your fashion that's your
statement so by just by way of your
whole discourse you're doing what you're
trying not to do it's kind of like um
well I guess I guess well I I guess I
should have phrased it differently what
I normally would wear is just stuff that
looks normal at least although I guess
yeah no I guess there is there is I
guess in this day and age you have to
make some kind of an effort so I guess
in you know in a horrible way I'm making
some kind of a fashion effort yeah no
you know you know you are though this is
what it feels like you know idea however
you want to explain this what if you
remember Bruce Lee when he was like on
the boat he was going to know which one
it was another dragon me know he's on
the boat right going over to yeah and
the guys like what's your style and he's
like my style is fighting without
fighting that's your style right there
it's fashion without fashion
Brow's looking at old pictures of us
like all like I don't know like oh nine
ten years ago yeah and and work is like
me UGA team was there and then you know
it's like whatever you being you same
you by the way they seem exactly normal
face and guess what you're wearing
victory t-shirt here yeah that's your
whole uniform ready I've got a lot of
them and it's you know
yes straightforward I dig it anyways
fashion without fashion that's jock
lovely weights got your back yeah I know
it's cool this is cool because Pete also
has a sense of that who else is making a
black on black sweatshirt right
there's no you can't see the origin of
you can see it but you got it you know
yeah you're not you're not drawing
attention to yourself yeah I guess
that's the thing right you're trying to
dry a tension juice yeah yeah yeah just
be a little bit more laid-back with that
stuff I feel it yeah they got cool guys
used to make fun of me at SEAL team too
cuz I had that was when I was competing
all the time in jiu-jitsu tournaments so
I had like and they said just like the
main thing you'd get from a juicy German
is a little cheesy medal and a t-shirt
t-shirt I had all these did I ever I had
a different t-shirt I had a different
jujitsu t-shirt so there guess what I
was doing one just wearing what I was
given but that's what it kind of stood
out yes yeah yeah even though these are
all just free t-shirts yeah yeah well
although I paid for the Hickson Gracie
won I had a cake some Gracie t-shirt I
paid some money for that one hey man
that's cool $12 the old Pico Street
Academy some old school people remember
that right now yeah we're best in the
west Best of the West loser
yeah I remember that but that was a
little later I'm talking old school
grappling games I'm talking Joel Moreira
no it's cool yes not my Tracy the Gracie
was a Gracie Invitational hmm greasy
nationals Gracie well I think it's it's
Canal what's called the grease now
neutral grounds memory lane with you
let's not do it but anyway yeah do
disagrees get get ordered and get all
origin stuff for jujitsu that's the
that's the spot to go even like the the
joggers and the sweats sweat stuff
mm-hmm most comfortable in the world
boom also supplement
you can get some supplements join war
effort getting some rave Lafe Avenue he
said he went off joint warfare I think
he's hit four or five days whatever's on
the trip sure
and he said his knee started hurting
again came back went back on the joint
warfare guess what knee healed up you I
mean he'll I don't know healed but it's
no no longer sore better yeah yeah man
that's how you know what you know so
funny is like me I'm all like surprised
when it my experience just like you know
he said obviously late surprised enough
to tell you about it you know and just
like me was like dang bro I told them I
told them we put illegal stuff enjoy it
warfare like I told no as I came in
don't tell anyone but we put some little
we put some little uh steroidal and and
he was all looking to be he'd he
probably me four point three seconds
because he didn't really believe me that
much but then I was like mom's kid man
but yeah anyways yet but nonetheless
isn't that supposed isn't that odd
though that were all surprise surprise
price it's supposed to do that you know
like it's supposed to do these things
yeah but I think it's a level that it
doesn't do is a little more though what
people expect yeah there you go get on
the car loyal to now discipline we've
got some debates going on on whether
Dave Bruno Dave Burke good deal yeah
whether he should be the actual
representative clearly he's the
representative discipline yes but for
Mulk
and the full milk train he's looking a
little lean yeah he's lean so he is the
lean representative milk
he's the before picture that's
cold-blooded well you know maybe know if
there's a letter like wait I don't want
to get all big hey Dave Burke he's on
the milk train fully on the milk train
yeah and he's not huge yeah well well
let's break it down so to me personally
I don't think Dave Burke should be the
poster child for milk
shindy wait is he treading on your
territory
that's classically anyway I sort of I
should have I should have read into this
more sorry bit so the idea he or the
reference could be technically he could
be so what protein right protein
additional protein because looking you
work out you lift you work out you do
you know all this extra hard exercise
boom protein is part of the recovery
process a big part of the recovery home
building blocks for lack of a better
term whatever and boom the Mont comes in
boom right but the milk tastes good
alright so here and here's this site no
this is why it's important for it to
taste good this may or may not go
against your whole actually will not
want it won't
seems like would but it tastes good so
let's say I'm like me I'm on the fence
about work you know I know you can't
relate to that part but let's say you
are but you're like wait but when I work
out I can take the milk so it like fits
in you know it one there's one with the
other that's the rest of those guys that
just thought just the supplements alone
would get them yeah exactly right yes
and that's part of the point is you
don't just just so everyone knows you
don't have to work out to have milk you
can have my uncle that working but it
will taste better if you worked out well
if you take milk or any problem like
additional protein for the reason you
take protein I'm saying and you don't
work out there's no reason to take it
true seem saying like any excess
calories settled for the fact that mold
tastes good just take mole just like
there's no reason to eat ice cream right
in chocolate or ice cream except for a
taste really good yeah but that's that's
a slippery slope no that's not the path
so officially by the way and we
established this this was I think I was
talking leaf weed the opposite of the
path is a slippery slope okay you can
step off the path for 10 minutes for one
day for one week but keep in mind the
more your the more time you spend on
this path you're gonna slay this a
slippery slope so poem unless if your
whole mindset is to drink milk just cuz
it tastes good no exercise know this but
you your your that's the wrong path
you're going in the wrong direction
they're full speed by the way you got a
foot on the slippery slope at that point
yeah and you kind of you're facing the
wrong way yeah that tastes good bomb
same reason but you're not you're saying
your pizza your two feet are
it's mostly one foots on the path Vulcan
working out you're on the path okay real
quick because we're getting crazy here
we got mint chocolate chip we got peanut
butter chocolate Dave Burke's favorite
mint chocolate it's my favorite what's
your favorite I mean to be in it yeah
but you mix them cuz you're psycho well
and then now new two new flavors are out
mmm vanilla gorilla and we got a
chocolate which is called
the darkness vanilla gorilla I was like
hey I know we need to make it vanilla
gorilla and then he wrote he like paused
we were texting and he's like wait
seriously and I was like yes then he
made a little crazy-looking vanilla
gorilla a little white gorilla
so anyways vanilla gorilla is the name
and the chocolate of course is called
darkness and if you don't know there are
layers to both those comments if you
know about the darkness then know that
one and if you know if you know life
well you can figure out the vanilla
gorilla yes these are all impeccable
things Kenneth yeah impeccable that
might not be the correct word but they
are impeccable things to stand keep you
on the path 20% indeed hundred percent
induce also chocolates doors called
Jocko store this is where you can get
shirts and hoodies and hats more rash
guards different feel different not
physical feel but different different do
is kinda this is pretty cool at the roll
call when we did jujitsu there was
people in the I've never done jujitsu
before area
they had rash guards yeah they had
chocolate or rash guards you know their
deaf core rash guards yeah and they had
origin rash guards yeah a lot of stuff a
lot that's a lot of when you just look
at that one room it was filled with a
lot of stuff that's made in America yeah
which is a big deal
it was and that says a lot for someone
who's never done jujitsu yet they have
the rash guard so that's kind of like in
a way I don't wanna say commitment
necessarily cuz this means good a quasi
could be more thing I bet you there was
people there that said I'm gonna try the
jujitsu and I'm gonna continue down the
path yeah
as people know you got
on the jiu jitsu path yeah that's just
part of the deal yeah I think well I had
a guy question me yeah at the roll call
after we got done teaching he's like so
his jujitsu the best you know thing to
start with as opposed to anything I was
like yeah man did you hear everything I
just said come on man
yeah do it yeah I said what about he
said what about what about like striking
though and I said well you know start
with boxing and get some more time when
you get good at boxing you can start
open it up a little bit
he's at oh shit I start with that I was
like no cuz if I grab you that's not
gonna work anymore right and if some bad
guy grabs you that's not gonna work
anymore anyways and I said yeah I always
try put myself in in like outside on my
own brain because you know when like if
someone asked me detached yeah if
they're like hey is you just to the best
marshal I'm like not even the other
options don't even enter you know it's
just like yes yes yes like constant yes
thing but I'm like wait you know let me
let me consider this you know and would
like try it I'd let go some of my bias
yeah anyway dr. Jocko store got some
good stuff on there if you wanna
represent the path this willing equals
freedom straight up cuz it does it's the
uniform for the path it is yes that's a
good way of putting it I would say
there's the new discipline equals
freedom sure yeah sure
is it different no is it standing out no
these things are all kind of you know
it's just these are these are fashion
items well but they do make us be doing
does that convey to everything my friend
yes sir there is you know yeah if you
want to represent gonna represent in the
wild rather word there were guys with
the shirt that you design with my head
on it
yep well I don't think I've ever felt
more honored in my life that was pretty
good who's pretty so multiple people
wearing the dang sure that you decide
and I designed you before I guess you
called the NAG shirt yeah well you know
now you're going deep disodium two
layers another anyway if you want to
represent jockle store calm also if you
want to support the message the word
what do you guys call it spreading the
word sort of pass
we're spread the word pass the word yet
you want to pass the word subscribe to
the podcast on iTunes and stitcher and
wherever you I mean seems obvious but
you know if you haven't subscribed
subscribe and don't leave Iran don't
forget about that war your kid podcast
yes which is you're gonna get lessons
from it for sure
your kids are gonna dig it and it's
gonna get your kids are we just gonna
talk about the path well it's gonna get
your kids on the path yes as well which
is awesome also get the they warrior
kids soap from iris Oaks ranch calm
that's Aiden he's a warrior kid he's got
his own business he's making soap and
that's awesome from goat milk of goats
that he raised himself and then he he
the whole process he sent me all these
pictures of it what he actually does
yeah he's got a manufacturing thing
going on in America yeah in America yes
by the way goats
the goats are American goats yeah also
YouTube we got the YouTube channel and
that is where that is where echoes legit
videos are and he's putting them up on a
pretty regular basis and he's got a plan
in place to increase that even more sure
and as long as that fits his schedule
and then we got psychological warfare
that's an album with tracks of me
talking and telling you why you should
do something instead of not do something
or why should not do something instead
of do something how to stay on the path
reason a slippery slope calls there you
go so get on that yeah that's available
through all the places you get mp3's
yeah what about a psychology core for -
it's common we're working at oh we're
working on it yes sir also on it comm
slash Chuck oh by the way this is where
you can get your other fitness gear so
remember back in the day we had the
there's actually back when when you were
explaining the essentials of home gym
yes right number one so look when you're
growing yeah number one is rings which I
got from on it by the way which actually
my kids enjoy those two the other phones
are nice nice quality quality
um nonetheless when you're expanding
your home gym in the event of you having
a home gym or even if you don't have a
home gym this is where you can get the
stuff to sort of begin that really good
stuff on there kettlebells is my I would
say that's my number one number one
thing to have that would be my
recommendation you see things you say we
can do pull-ups on kettlebells bro no
way do you like pull-ups I like pull up
why can't really dumb now I don't know
what in your game when you're when
you're when you're a hundred percent
yeah and I mean yes but not like you
like polo like it's you know how you
have your the ones you like yeah like I
when I started kettlebells I really
liked them I thought is super fun cuz
there's a lot anyway they're fun and I
get on from on it and there's a lot of
cool other cool stuff on there so yeah
go on it calm slash Jocko also jock a
white tee you can get the tea bags or
you get the can and when you get the tea
bags or you get the can either one it
doesn't matter because what you get with
that you get a eight thousand pound
deadlift 100% guaranteed although I did
have one guy complain at roll call his
deadlifts only seven thousand four
hundred so probably yeah he's probably I
told him to get after it harder he and
then you've got some books also the the
tea is available on Amazon in the store
and uncle Jocko store there you go I
figure ultimately you we will unify yeah
well I guess the kind of goal like short
term clothes kind of make it just
available yeah if you're gonna grab a
shirt rash guard whatever and you're
like hey let me grab tea - good point I
thought I saw an Amazon store when we
were in Dallas
we ordered on Amazon store an Amazon
like obvious shipping facility this
thing was huge and it was surrounded by
trucks that were backed up to it you
know loading docks just it was crazy
there's totally nuts and I was like in
there somewhere
there's a little bit of jock a white tee
getting ready to roll out and increase
somebody's deadlift it looks in there
they also had books in there you know
Jaakko books choco books yes they had
way too warrior kid mm-hmm you think
they had that one nice no did yeah they
absolutely do
they had the Field Manual so the way the
Worker kid and marks mission
I signed so many of those books at roll
call and of the personal messages to the
kids and everything the kids are getting
on the path this is factual mmm
awesome so get the books for your kids
and get them a pull-up bar and get them
a jiu-jitsu class because that's what
they're gonna want to do and those two
things are gonna help them through their
entire life yeah their entire life yeah
and that's actually good heads up cuz
like if you're like hey you already got
the pull-up bar and like the jujitsu
classes scouted out you know and then so
you're just ready you ready for the
request you know as your kids are gonna
be they're gonna they're gonna want to
get on the path yeah and I think who's
you I was telling this to where I was
reading the part where he has to fix up
his bike see I don't want to spoil
anything but anyway he needed money okay
I need money so he's like hey do you get
money you gotta you gotta get a job and
you know it lays out the whole thing all
the layers of like dang that's pretty
good so right after I was done with that
chapter my five-year-old daughter by the
way oh because she kind of sits back
almost disappointed looking she goes
just I wish I had a job I don't think I
ever felt like I was telling a work
ethic into a kid that's five years old
about wanting to work and wanting to
learn and wanting to have a job and
wanting to that's just like legit yeah
so get those books way the word kid
marks mission you can also get the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual I
suppose under ton of those yeah again
that there's there's some people that
that book hit them hard yeah hard and
they made some significant changes in
her life so everyone that came up to me
and told me that thank you and I
appreciate that feedback and it's
awesome to see that book hitting people
the way that it hit me when I wrote it
yeah and it's awesome sick in fact that
beginning part is what you're reading
today there is no hack yeah there's no
sweat list
pursue the sweat list pursuit sweat list
direction yeah definitely and then of
course there's extreme ownership which
was written by me and my brother late
babban combat leadership for use in your
business and life then we also have this
week just released so this this is live
now at this time order it immediately
the dichotomy a leadership a couple
reviews already up there because some
people got some advance copies awesome
reviews everyone is stoked including
including me and Lafe you know we wrote
it and you know we'd entered each other
and it'd be like bro nice Jaffrey be
like bro nice drafter like a you know so
yeah we critique each other and added
each other
so the book is it just takes it to
another granular level that's what it
does takes it down to another granular
level I think and some people are saying
that they're more people gonna get more
out of that economy leadership than they
didn't off extreme ownership hmm they
definitely compliment each other but
there's a lot to be learned a lot of the
mistakes that people make are gonna be
corrected through the de kata me of
leadership yeah yeah cuz you know when
people make a change in their whatever
you know make it's like what he could
actually you're the first time I heard
this over correct over correct yes yes
people over correct people over correct
all the time
and they they throw off the balance of
the dichotomy of leadership yeah and so
when you read the dichotomy of
leadership you'll become aware of that
you'll see what the signs are and you'll
be able to correct them and this is
gonna this is gonna really help out
leaders in in the world so dichotomy
leadership available now I have me know
think that this books been in the work
for a long time and now it's out it's
released it's in the wild so get some
get some for your people you work with
appreciate that support and then of
course got a leadership company
leadership consulting company excellent
front or we solve lead we solve problems
through leadership that's what we do
it's me it's lave Babb and Jay
Peter nel Dave Burke Flynn Cochran Mike
Sorelli we also got Mike Beaumont did
you you they're from like Bahamas part
of roll call mean good Mike main gun
Mike felt like a numerator yeah so we
got another member army retired
lieutenant colonel who was with us in
the battle Ramadi a company commander
then tanker and badass if you want if
you need help leadership at your company
with your team whatever it may be go to
Ashland front comm we've also got the
muster coming up roll calls done sorry
you missed it it was awesome come next
time in the meantime muster 0:06
san francisco october 17th and 18th
we're danger-close right now if you if
you hear this podcast and you listen to
it on you know in september hopefully
maybe i don't know check the website
extreme ownership calm all of them sold
out or danger close on this one but
check it out we can sometimes squeeze in
a few more seats and of course we also
have EF overwatch EF overwatch comm this
is for businesses for businesses that
want leaders tested battle tested
Special Operations leaders from the
Special Operations community or from a
combat aviation community you want those
people those leaders at your business go
to EF overwatch comm that we are we have
our friends our colleagues people we
know our connections inside the Special
Operations and inside the combat
aviation community they're trained
they're ready and they will come and
help your business through solid
leadership again that's EF overwatch
comm and if you want to keep
communicating with us then you can do it
through the interwebs through Twitter
perhaps through Instagram or on the face
echo is at echo Charles and I am at
jockey willing and thanks to all of you
that make this podcast possible and
that's not some big corporate sponsor no
it's the military personnel around the
world that keep our country free it's
all the first responders out there
police law enforcement correctional
officers firefighters Border Patrol
paramedics all of you that keep us safe
on the homefront thanks to all of you
for what you do and everyone else that's
out there thank you for listening thank
you for spreading the word thank you for
supporting what we do but most of all
thanks for telling yourself the truth
thanks for not looking for that sweat
list solution or that easy road because
the sweat list solution and the easy
road don't exist to get on the path and
to stay on the path that gets you to
where you want to be there is going to
be sweat and there's going to be hard
work and there's going to be discipline
and you're going to have to look at
yourself and tell yourself the truth and
then of course you're gonna have to get
after it
and until next time this is echo and
Jocko out